when I saw what was happening on that
beach area I stopped bodies floating and
when my mind was flashing through
there's a son a father that won't be
coming home this week's episode of the
Sunday special is gonna be a little bit
different in just a few days June 6
that'll be the 75th anniversary of d-day
the Allied invasion in Normandy the
beginning of the end of Nazi domination
in Europe in today's episode I'll be
interviewing four very special veterans
who fought in World War two some in
Normandy itself Jack Guttman George
Champa my clavier and Tom rice I'm
honored to have been able to spend time
with these men and I hope that you enjoy
hearing their stories well I'm eager to
welcome to the program tom rice he's a
member of the one hundred and first
Airborne Division during d-day
mr. rice thank you so much for joining
the show so what was it like to jump
into the middle of the firestorm on
d-day well there's a lot of answers to
that question but mainly it was chaos
chaos chaos and so everything that his
chaotic probably occurs in route though
we were stationed at Merrifield
Airport 501 battalion 1 was there 506
battalion 3 and 326 airborne engineers
all boarding 45 aircraft in section 14
we headed down the runway in one
aircraft now there was a fella who was
injured on one of the practice jumps and
he was in the hospital he broke loose
from the hospital and wasn't going to
miss this escapade and he got to the
airport but without proper equipment but
the kids ravel scrap injured up some
stuff for him and he got in the plane
and took the one spot open and
lieutenant Hamilton's aircraft and a
rifleman whatever
LLC was supposed to have and and as the
plane was taking off a rifle shot fired
in the aircraft and lieutenant Hamilton
walked up and down the center aisle
between the 18 guys wanna know who did
it
towards nobody's going to tell but he
finally found out and he picked up this
guy by the shoulder straps and lifted
him up and banged his head against the
bulkhead took him down to the door and
threw him out and the court of inquiry
came into being and exonerated the
lieutenant Hamilton said he had all the
right to do that and the guy could have
been shot for doing that but that was
one the answer so we took off and I
always jump number one and I could see
all that was going on and I was looking
down at 750 feet with a high altitude
and above the door there are three
lights a white light green light and a
red light
as we touched the coast the white light
goes out and the red light goes on it
gives us about eight minutes of time to
get ready so what was happening in the
aircraft it was that lieutenant
Jansen was jump master and he got
everybody by verbal signals and two hand
signals because we did have did not have
a door on the aircraft this just didn't
wasn't there took it off and it wasn't
there so there's the hand signal to
stand up and hook up we hooked up to a
steel cable that was about three to four
eighths of an inch in diameter and ran
from the pilots cabin to the aft of a
little compartment there and we snapped
fastened on that lieutenant Jensen went
to a number 18 man or he was 18 man and
he checked the equipment on number 17
man and sounded off everything's okay 17
checked 16 and on up to me and I'm in
the door and we were trying to try we
were traveling 176 miles an hour and
that's too fast we were jumping
low how low I'm not sure it got no proof
but it was low somewhere around 500 feet
I guess and my left foot was in the
doorway Janssen announces everybody
ready so we fill the air with sulfurous
fumes of acid words and and yeah word
get the hell out of here as fast as we
can we could unload that aircraft in
between 10 and 18 seconds I guess and
everybody's pushing from the rear so his
last word is uh for the most part to
stand in the door and so here I am
repositioning the door and with that
speed when I went out the plane went up
about 50 feet I think and because of the
a six pair packs were job dropped called
simultaneously and so that made it a
much lighter load and so that kind of
glued me to the floor my hands on the
outside of the door and as I stepped out
now that the prop last caught me and
slammed me up against the outside of the
aircraft my left arm got caught in the
lower left-hand corner of the door so I
swung out came back in body upside down
reserve parachute up to my face and used
that bag half way up there also and I
hit the side of the aircraft and bounced
back out again and I came back and hit
and just hit the side of it and the
Resta guy to the guys in this thick were
going out under me and and as I as I
came in the second time I just was able
to turn a little bit in and as I release
my arm from the side of the door and I
had a two hundred and fifty dollar
walsim wristwatch on with a face toward
the palm and that's great that often I
lost that one I hope some good Frenchmen
got it so I fell free and then I was
down with a stretch out of the risers
and then the parachute canopy and the
event picked collar at the top of the
parachute for the most part was
not large enough to take care of all the
flow of the air so well I started to
oscillate right and dump it out and
swing to the left and dump it out and
and within a matter of five or six
seconds I'd was on the ground and with
all that padding in front of me I made a
right forearm parachute landing fall
didn't get injured so here I am
well once once you had landed what was
the next move was to meet up with the
rest of the people in your well the next
thing was to get out of that harness and
everything was so tight that I couldn't
and I had a double zipper here on my
jumpsuit with a switchblade knife in it
and that's why I reach for that and
opened it up got the switchblade knife
pushed the button out flips the blade
and I start sawing the way your webbing
trying to get loose from that number two
and three men came up they had the
mortar so we had to jump a little canal
so we didn't we recognized each other
five or six of us got together there on
the roadside and one of them one of them
said to me I have a hand grenade with
the pin pulled
I said all right give it to me but once
you can't put a pin back in a hand
grenade got a little bad end on it and
that's it he might have pulled it and
didn't know what to do with it and or
threw it away but okay give me the hand
grenade everybody down I took it and
holds tires I put a death grip on that
thing so that the spoon wouldn't slip
out of my hand if it did I got five
seconds so I rolled over at that side
the road and dropped in a canal and
rolled back in the sand of the road and
it exploded and sent shrapnel around and
went water and mud splatter dust so we
got up and no for the most part we began
to break up and but six of us went down
the road - so I saw a small house on the
side of the road well we got more hand
grenades we got German so let's
investigate twice another fella and I
flowed Martin and I went to the front
door and I said slow don't bang on the
door like an ugly American just knock on
it you know and we'll see what happens
and arrest the guys I sent him around
the back in case there were Germans in
there so the Frenchman finally came to
the door and he had a white nightgown
from shoulder all the way to the floor
he had a white tousled cap with a puff
ball on the end of it same white and I I
pictured him as Scrooge and so I started
to laugh and like yeah I know I was
getting in danger when I came back to my
senses because once you get your mind
taken out of the danger into something
that is for the most part could happen
in a city you've got a problem so I
really quickly came back to senses that
I was in danger so we pushed him aside
he was blase because it's been occupied
by Germans for four or five years and
put the map on the floor and pointed in
three different directions and sounded
off of the name Karen town and he
pointed in the right direction and the
meantime his wife came in dressed the
same way and he excused himself and he
came back in about five seconds twenty
five to twenty seconds and he had some
ammunition gave us six and he kept two
when you first jumped out I mean it
sounds like it was you you mentioned
that it was chaos you came in and it was
silent were correct I mean where it was
their fire where were you under fire
when the planes were dropping you well
there's so much noise you really don't
know but I could see the burst of flame
and a hurricane of fire came up general
form of a rectangle and I knew we were
heading toward that rectangle and
luckily the pilot swung way to the right
and that took us away from the drop zone
B toward dropzone D and I just ended up
on the southern end of drop zone D so
what was your first interaction like
with the enemy when you did hit the
ground the six German parachute infantry
regiment was having a party one night
the June 5th one of the platoons or
rather one of the yes yes platoons was
at that the beach causeway for and our
mission was to hold causeway two three
and four so the beach forces coming in
could go through us and continue on into
the hedgerows and chase the Germans out
we ended up there at a place called
hell's corner all of this was going on
and we spotted the Germans coming in
toward us from Causeway Fork so for the
most part having fun smoking and a rifle
slung on their shoulder and not thinking
there's any enemy around we was also
observed from Carentan from by the 1st
or 2nd german regiment and they they
were pretty my optic because they saw
Germans and they saw Americans milling
around down and didn't know what to do
so we set up a defense and the Germans
walked right into it
we fired on him who had machine guns and
mortars on both the ends of the
defensive line and the regimental
Colonel Howard Johnson took two German
speaking gi's went out and tried to get
a hold of the regimental Colonel of the
German contingency and he did and he
said you guys are ready to surrender he
said no it's too early to surrender we
don't surrender under these conditions
so they turned around walked back in
they got fired on and half an hour later
they went out and tried it again and
they told the the regimental colonel
German regimental colonel that they to
have the men that are wounded put
bayonets on their rifles jabbed him in
the ground put their rifle but or there
were a helmet on the rifle but and will
come out and pick him up and was we'll
have a truce or a half an hour so for
the most part that was what was going on
now back at Hill's corner I was right
next to a lieutenant who had jumped with
us and he had the communications with
the United States naval ship Quincy and
and he was trying to communicate with
him because Colonel Johnson watered fire
put on there our rear end of our column
because the Germans are coming down from
Cherbourg on in 13 and
to invade the area and you know get in
behind us we were surrounded every time
we went in we were surrounded but we
didn't want that to happen so he was
making contact and they used the
baseball lingo and from lamar's Bert who
won this game and who Annette whose
national champion had said so they made
good communication and there were three
rounds fired I think there were 18 inch
guns I'm not sure of it but they were
big heavy ones and and I heard blow the
first round whistle over my head and boy
what a racket it made it was long second
one was short the third one was right on
and from there I was given the detail to
take two men and go to la barqueta luck
and I'll post it that's why we went over
to the library at Locke and I set up a
defensive system the locks were closed
the folders were flooded and for the
most part the ones that were not flooded
had Rommel asparagus stuck in the ground
they were poles trees that were stripped
to bark and branches pointed and jammed
in the ground and then wire strung from
treetop to treetop and on some of them
they had mines that was an anti glider
activity that took place and anti
parachute they told us before we jumped
make sure your legs are crossed when you
come down relax your angles ankles and
and hope for the best
so crossing the law Burkett luck decided
not to go into the house because if
anyone any one patrol came through they
could surround us set it on fire drive
us out and we didn't do us in real quick
so we we set up in the orchard right
next to the house the right-hand side of
the house and we were about hold ten
yards apart and we knew we knew we've
had a pretty good idea we're being
observed
because the Germans that turned on what
above sea level and we were to say there
until called back on the sixth as the
daybreak was coming into being I set up
a series of steel stakes and strung wire
between the steel stakes and hung tin
cans full of bolts and nuts and rocks
from the wires and stretched it across
the area that they might approach a
German patrol might approach from the
left absolutely no talking whatsoever
from this point on and until the next
morning
if anything happens if any rattling
occurs just start shooting and so at
2:00 in the morning we started shooting
yeah we got one he laid out there for
quite some time moaning and groaning and
the girdling sound of a dying man stops
all conversations as general so once the
guys had some mortuary experience he
went out with his trench and knife and
finished him off and in the morning we
pulled the guy in and and
dug a trench for him and under an apple
tree and I took a couple branches and
broke them and made a Christian cross
and put it at the head of it and I cut
off his wings I still have the wings on
the book I wrote and I never get caught
whether Germans who when you're in your
pants or your pocket or any worker
they'll do you in especially less guys
with baggy pants as we called the
Germans green Devils Folsom joggers
green Devils so we stayed there until
June 7th and then will call back and put
in reserve because really if 1st and 4th
Infantry Division had already moved
through us well more than just one
second but first it's summer the only
thing more annoying than fake news are
flies and other insects invading your
home who knows where those flies were
last the fly that just landed on your
hamburger could have been from anywhere
from another piece of food to well think
about it so we'd like to thank our
sponsors over at dynatrap
trap is the leading manufacturer of
outdoor mosquito and insect traps now
they've come up with a solution for
indoor pests the dynatrap fly light the
dynatrap fly light works day and night
to attract and trap flies fruit flies
mosquitoes other pesky insects I've got
to say it really does work
forget those disgusting fly strips the
dynatrap fly light looks like a subtle
nightlight that plugs into any indoor
outlet trust me I've been using the
dynatrap fly light for a couple of days
now it is insane the number of insects
it is caught that would otherwise be
buzzing around my home get yours right
now at dynatrap calm that's dy and a TR
AP comm enter the promo code daily wire
receive 15% off any of their products
dynatrap the safe silent simple solution
to household insect control go check
them out right now at dynatrap that's dy
and a TR ap comm dynatrap comm go check
them out right now use promo code daily
wire get 15% off any of their products
so you're going back now on the 75th
anniversary of d-day and you're actually
jumping out of a plane again
you're 97 years old on a c-47 the first
one I'm gonna took place in the invasion
is that how do you feel about that great
I'm gonna jump tandem this time and
there go for the ride so I think there's
been more than one in the aircraft
they're gonna jump a static line maybe
1200 feet and then I gotta go I got to
go to 13,000 and we're gonna have an
American flag French flag and 101st
Airborne Division flag I think we're
gonna tether it from weights and
attached a little till the harness and
we come in we're supposed to be
spectacular we did it before at that
mount pull year of the year before and
it was it worked out very nice so how
old were you when you when you jumped
out the first time first combat jump 20
20 almost 21 what what was your kind of
training when you when you first when
you'd first jumped out how much training
did you have to go through to become 2
year in there trooper 2 years plus we
had for the most part and we did
anything and everything and anything and
everything was experimental
because airborne activities were so new
that it was experimental all away what
was your most
ethical jump most difficult one he was
that first one an enormity LMI jumps
were great except that normally one and
those were things that I thought that
they had thought of but nobody ever
thought about a plane going up maybe 30
40 or 50 feet when the pair packs were
dumped and I thought machine-gun bullets
was going to come up through the bottom
of the aircraft and just strike me and
chin and hit me hit me in the vital
spots and change my plumbing well thank
you so much for everything that you've
done and congratulations on the on the
upcoming jump we'll certainly be
watching good luck with that obviously
thank you so much for stopping by so
we're here with first lieutenant Michael
leviair who's b-24 navigator in the
European theater thank you so much for
your time I really do appreciate it I'll
begin with this where was your first
mission as a flyer my first mission was
to test what they called Azon bombings
we were chosen to take this new device
out where the bombs had fins on him that
were radio control and we dropped these
bombs and we could actually move them Oh
correct its course couldn't move him
anyway this way you know great was that
movable but the course was and we flew
to missions like that and they were off
the coast of Denmark some target off the
coast it was a oil refinery actually we
were supposed to hit and I found that to
be a rather easy mission they usually
gave you an easy one to get you used to
flying you know to learn the ropes so to
speak now they call it a milk one but I
never like to turn milk one because even
on a milk run somebody is shooting flaca
if shooting eighty-eights at you and if
one piece hits you and kills you it
wasn't a milk run and I remembered it
was a lot of life when you've got flak
on every city that were very well
defended but we would we did mostly
daylight bombing so we could we could
see these guns firing at us you know it
was black when I went off when I shall
in 88 millimeter shell explodes the
airplane all you see is a big puff of
black smoke and a flesh and
you don't hear anything really it's not
that close to you because if it gets any
closer
you're gone I mean the shrapnel every
mission we went on we came home with
holes in the airplanes little because
you know when when a shell goes off it's
just splat as a whole area with flak
what they call flak which is just
fragments of metal and we had a lot of
holes fortunately none of the holes were
critical so we always got back on on our
mission the second mission I flew was a
rather difficult one I think we went to
Magdeburg which is deep in Germany and
that's what I really saw people getting
knocked out of the sky things like that
it was quite quite a sight to see a
plane get hit and spiraled down and see
parachutes coming out of them and
falling to the ground and unless you
actually see the real thing
can't imagine how frightening that is
you know that it could have been you and
you wind up in Germany in a prisoner of
war camp but I seen quite a few of that
I was very lucky that we never got
seriously hit the way we had to abort
abort the mission because we were struck
by a German fire we actually aborted a
mission because something went wrong
with the airplane we had to come home
but the way you were you know you got
credit for every mission that you
dropped your bombs over enemy territory
to a certain target they gave you
certain targets of opportunity which
meant that if you had to abort you could
pick one of these talkers of opportunity
vomit make a record of it and they would
give you credit for a mission so how
many missions did you actually end up
flying so I did a total of 36 combat
missions and what that did not include
several other missions which included
bringing gasoline supplies to General
Patton who was running up the at that
time by the time I had to do that he was
moving up the French into Belgium and he
had run out of gasoline or was running
short on gasoline and what they did to
our b-24s in our squadron was take the
bomb racks out and put two 500-gallon
gasoline
tanks in here to carry automobile
gasoline because that's what his tanks
used these were called gas hauled
missions and since they were
administrative type missions they were
not counted as a regular mission but
they I'm my opinion they were more
dangerous than a regular mission because
of the amount of gasoline that was
actually around in and around the
airplane from slightly sand the tanks
you know and the fumes were you couldn't
smoke would get anywhere near fire their
plane would blow up and we had four
tanks and wings we had to Tokyo tanks
and two main tanks and so they we just
flew with the Tokyo tanks with aviation
gas and the first place we landed was
cluster as france where on landing it
was such a the Germans had just left
that area about three days prior to us
landing there and there was quite a few
bomb holes in the runway and so when I
finally got there I asked the pilot says
do you think we could land on that short
of runway he says we've got him we got
to get rid of this gasoline so we flew
very low over the runway to look at it
and I said there's a lot of holes in
that runway
he says what we're gonna land anyway
unfortunately at that point my pilot had
overshot the end of the runway too far
in and we wound up going off the end of
the runway into a a meadow of mud and a
plane sank that right down on the bomb
bay is and we were so afraid of the
plane exploding we all just got out of
it and grin like heck thanks to get out
of the way and the only other missions
that I did that I did not get credit for
was at the end of the war many of the
ground people at service the airplanes
at the air base during the war were now
able to get in the airplane we took ten
of ten of them at a time and flew him
over Germany over the rooftops to show
them the amount of damage in the German
and I'm telling you it wasn't a rooftop
left in Germany when we got through it I
mean it was really destroyed so in a
second I only asked you what it was like
both dropping the bombs and also being
on the other end of receiving flak but
first time has a habit of getting away
but if you've got a mortgage or kids or
anybody depending on your income you're
gonna have to spend some of that
precious time getting life insurance if
you need life insurance but you don't
want to spend a lot of time comparing it
you should give policy
genius a try policy genius is the easy
way to buy life insurance online in just
two minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers and find your best
price once you do apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork on the red tape for you no
Commission's no hidden fees just more
time safe for you policy genius doesn't
just make life insurance easy they also
do home insurance and auto insurance
disability insurance they are
one-stop-shop for financial protection
so if you need life insurance but you're
short on time head on over to policy
genius calm and comparequotes policy
genius is easy it saves you money not to
belabor the point but it is indeed fast
policy genius spend less time comparing
life insurance more time doing literally
anything else be a responsible adult
make sure that everybody is taken care
of in case god forbid something happens
to you go check out policy genius right
now check them out of policy genius com
so what was the the mission that scared
you the most we've talked about a couple
of the the gassho missions he's talked
about seeing the other airplanes you
know exploding for Thea the most
dangerous mission I think was so Sidon
and Berlin because the fortifications
around Berlin and the amount of guns
that they had down and defending the
city wasn't incredible I mean it the sky
was just black with black and zosyn was
similar to Camp David it was their
headquarters where all of the German
high mucky-mucks two generals and all
that would meet to plan out maneuvers or
whatever to enhance their position in
the war and we were we've found out
through intelligence that there was
going to be a big German meeting of very
important generals and and high people
in the German army that were going to
meet there and this was close to the end
of the war ready you know they were
losing a war pretty bad by that time and
we bombed zosyn I have never seen so
much flak I mean it was the sky was
black with it so on d-day what was your
involvement with the invasion I was in
the second a division of the 8th Air
Force the 96th combat wing which
consisted of 3 groups one of mine was a
four 58th Bomb Group and I was involved
in the d-day landings flying one mission
that Dave to bomb air fills in somewhere
behind the lines where they were going
to invade Normandy
you know we were really aware of what
was going on you know that we were not
before it was very secretive before the
invasion and we were just assigned a
mission and it happened to be you know
the d-day landings and we knew there was
a lot of shifts in the channel at the
time what's going on there was this big
thing and we did our mission bombed this
airfield and came home how exact could
you be with the with the bombing given
the technology and the and the
construction lobby the Norden bombsight
that we used at the time was fairly
accurate however only the lead the lead
plane actually aimed the bombs the rest
of the planes in the Swami ssin there
could be as many as 50 or 100 maybe as
high as 400 planes in a formation they
would drop on smoke markers at the end
that the lead planes would drop they
would locate the target and the
Bombardier in that plane would aim the
bombs and then the rest of the formation
would just drop on his smoke walkers and
the accuracy was as good as the guy that
did the initial ami if he missed
everybody missed and that was the case
most of the time believe it or not as
good as the bomb site was if there was
so much bad weather during the winters
and when we were bombing that we never
saw the ground half the time you know
we'd get a little break in the clouds
and drop his bombs and everybody would
drop their bombs with the on the smoke
and if he missed everybody missed and
once he joined what was it was the
training regimen like to become a flyer
well they picked us up we got on the
train we wound up at Keesler Field
Mississippi where we initially took our
basic training for flight duties you
know and you still you will classify two
or three but you hadn't been determined
whether you would be a pilot Obama dear
a navigator it depended on what the Air
Force needed at the time the Air Corps
needed a tire there was not the air
force that it was called the Army Air
Corps so we're part of the army I had
trouble passing through the oxygen the
high-altitude oxygen chamber test that's
a test where they put you into the
chamber and they simulate well they
don't simulate what they actually
decompressed the chamber until you reach
what is the equivalent of about 35,000
feet and you spend about an hour in
there and at that altitude you take your
mask off your oxygen mask so you could
feel what anoxia which is a lack of
oxygen would feel like if it happened up
in the air they'd ask you to try to
write or talk and speak like that and so
you would learn what it felt like wish
you didn't have a really rate I couldn't
pass that test because previous to my
entrance into the Army I had an accident
where I broke both my kneecaps and
apparently when I got at that altitude I
got a lot of pain in my knees from
wobbles or something I don't know what
it was anyway I had to be decompressed
and taken out of the chamber and then
they rescheduled me to try it again
because I never told him about the
accident how they have told man I got a
washed-out right away because you can't
have broken bones and become an air cold
man
I was rescheduled for this test
meanwhile the other people that were in
the chamber with me and he was all these
people that were LK cells and Em's you
know is their last name had shipped out
to Kingman Arizona for a night gunnery
training and while they were that
Kingman Arizona these people were on a
bus going tonight gunnery practice and
that bus was hit by a Southern Pacific
freight train going sixty or seventy
miles an hour and killed them all these
are all the guys and they were all
killed one day I was coming out of
school at Coral Gables at the University
and this news kid was hacking he is 27
Air Cadets killed in Arizona blah blah
blah you know so I bought a newspaper
and I was a I was astonished at what I
read had I have passed that test I would
have been on that bus so what what was
the rest of your crew like so that you
served with the same crew for the entire
no I did not fly with the same crew
I flew about I'd say around 18 missions
with my initial crew and at the end
the war I was assigned to take it they
they were gonna send me back my ship and
I didn't want to do that I want to come
back with it with it with an airplane so
they said well if you get a spot on that
from some kind of needed a navigator you
would get home because the crude I was
flying with they dispersed and they were
broken up I don't know where they all
went but what I did is I got ahold of a
friend of mine that knew a pilot that
needed a navigator and I got it on that
crew and flew a b24 back from my airbase
back to Boston and at that time the
Japanese were still fighting in the
Pacific and so they reassigned us to go
into b-29 training and during that time
the atom bomb was dropped and of course
there was no need to do anything further
so that was all cancelled and we were
sent up to Fort Dix New Jersey for well
they gave you a choice did you want to
stay in or did you want to get out if
you had enough combat points you could
get out which I did so well went up to
Fort Dix and was discharged at Fort Dix
Wow my clavier thank you so much for
your time I really appreciate you
stopping by thank you very much joining
us is Jack Guttman Navy corpsman who
served on the beaches of Normandy and
Okinawa mr. Guttman thanks so much for
joining us so what was it like to be
serving on d-day what was your
experience like well we hit that Beach
there was no deal where you could land
right on the sand or anything there was
barriers and it turned out as what I did
is later on was to find out after 66
years of post-traumatic stress
what the heck happened because when I
came on their 18 year old mind oh yeah I
stopped bodies floating I saw body
Underland out on the beach body parts
all over and it was so tough too well
I may be confronted I've seen blood and
so forth in other things but I tell
people have you seen Saving Private Ryan
well I says this kind of kind of doubled
that a little bit because the one thing
all Private Ryan didn't show us all the
body parts laying around and then my
mind was flashing through there's the
son a father that won't be coming home
and you're in a I'm scared as hell I had
I just had boil be scared seeing wounded
people and what was going on and there
was firing on the beach when we arrived
even at that time there was firing I
don't know where I was from but there
was explosions there were mines all over
the beaches and all and what I had to
find out which I found out later why in
the heck that this happened why did we
lose 9,000 men you know and for them for
that battle then when I read about it
the big problem was they shelled the
beaches and then they were supposed to
send over there was actually five
thousand ships eleven thousand planes
there was 4,500 lcvps a landing craft of
various times and then there was a
hundred and fifty thousand troops
Englishmen and Americans all it was a
massive force was something you figure
you this is beyond comprehension and
then I found out why we lost so many men
it turned out that the planes that were
supposed to hit the bunkers
there was cloud cover and they they said
that we can't see the beach that would
think when it is drop the bombs so they
dropped the bombs of mile Lovely's past
there and the bunkers were not hit at
all and they had some machine guns which
I found out could shoot off a hundred
and fifty bullets a minute or more and
just mowed these poor guys in the first
second third wave or whatever it is they
was just and one of the prime
what happened that's what we saw so many
bodies in the water no is that guys were
jumping off which I found out even from
some of the wounded there I was asking
what what's happened below and these the
guys were scared and when they dropped
the ramp and and machine guns were
mowing the guys down they jumped off the
side of the boat now when that happened
all of a sudden these heavy packs that
they have on them which is at least 50
pounds or more and they went right down
they couldn't if they couldn't get the
packs off they'd drown so some guys
never even got a shot off or anything
like that and it was just one heck of a
mess on that whole thing but that done
on that beach what would you do from
there with the wounded my job was to
assist the medical group that was
already there
there were guys that were that had been
patched up on all and there was other
guys that are not and I I tell people
when no matter what they're doing and
when I speak at different places when
you were on a team and you're doing
things never think you are no man on the
totem pole because when I was going and
I was a corpsman first class really one
of the lowest man on the totem pole I
was a medic to do something but I found
one interesting thing when you come upon
the wounded and the guy is pleading doc
help me or am I gonna make it and you
look at him gushing blood and you're
putting packs on him and giving him a
shot of morphine but the threats you
know I almost said and I realized now I
think about it
that to that man I was the most
important thing in his life and then and
I tried to tell people no matter where
you are on the totem pole you do your
job and do it right we went from one to
the other some guys it was the strangest
thing that watch how some people died
like one guy was talking mean he says
doc I finally I got wounded but I'm
go home and he says I'll make it right
doc and I said yeah you're gonna make it
and then he dies
it was strange you know and then I've
seen other deaths where people just wind
up almost sit up and talk to you a
little bit then then they go back and
die time just flies by you keep you go
from one to the other and then there's
some people you have to redress because
when the first medics go through they
leave them there for there to be
evacuated and that was going to be part
of our job so you the blood gushing so
much that you have to redress it and now
you can't take the hold the one that's
on you're gonna take it off you just put
a new one on I have to admit myself I
was really scared I'd be there was when
you see what I saw there and this is an
18 year old mind and there was guys that
I saw dead there and I thought of the
guys on the ship earlier that day
laughing and kidding around and all this
it was just a horrible thing and so we
evacuated these people back on - I think
it's like those flats thing like you
could put a lot of bombed wounded on
there so we did that we loaded them on
and then finally I think them then we
went back with the wounded taking care
of whatever wounded we had back to the
hospital which was Netley England now
there was a guy there I took care of he
became almost like friends with me
this officer he was young lieutenant and
he was telling me about his wife and kid
and I and I just felt for him but he was
losing spinal fluid and when you lose
spinal fluid you I asked the doctor is
he going to make it and doctor said no
he won't
and he was talking to me and he says you
know I'm looking forward to getting home
to my wife and he's saying thanks for
helping me I know you're doing the best
for me and I'm looking forward now I'll
remember you and I know he's gonna die
and when he died he wanted to delirium
because when you lose spinal fluid all
kinds of things happen and then if a man
dies on your watch when you're in the
hospital with him not on the beach or
anything but there you have to pack
every cavity in his body so he won't
leak before rigor mortis sets in and I
had to do this four times here in
Okinawa and everything else and I'll
tell you Ben it becomes very personal
pen
it's obviously harrowing stuff and he
had some experiences in the Pacific
Theater as well well for instance I was
there the English Hospital put there for
over a month taken care of then they
gave me 30 they leave 15 they leaved
and then I figured I'm going to go to a
a stateside hospital you know duty I've
already served my day I went through
this hell and all of a sudden they
needed medics because they were knocking
off the medics see in Normandy we landed
with the red Red Cross and a patch on on
this arm and that was fine but in
Okinawa they we they did it in the
beginning and then the Japanese but it
was a target so they were killing the
medics off and so therefore there was a
big brush to have a bunch of medics over
there so I guess whether I had Normandy
invasion or whatever the duty they
needed medics and I wound up there so
next thing I was on a ship called the
buoy and we went on to Okinawa and they
made the invasion there and we lost 14
thousand men in Okinawa but that
finished sixty-two thousand wounded I
tell you and these are all young people
and you see so much death and everything
like that I think the picture hacksaw
Ridge brought out a very good thing on
that thing and I realized that at that
time there
I was probably taking care of a lot of
that wounded I didn't know about hacksaw
Ridge or anything like that but then the
other thing in Okinawa that was horrible
was the kamikaze planes the kamikaze
planes of these young guys that give it
they got a bomb on the on the ship and
they fly over and they just go right
into the ship well I was just finishing
taking care of some patients on my ship
the buoy and I'm up on deck having a
cigarette I smoked two packs a day then
I don't smoke anymore and what happened
then is that all of a sudden a big gun
went off right near me and that caused
me to lose half my hearing on that on
that and I'm in here battle stations so
I'm learning and all these kamikaze
planes are coming in and then I see them
some are hitting some of the ships well
I'm running to the the sickbay deals
have not done that there I kid you not
there's a picture right I had my files
and all it's in my book too in this book
here and that there was I saw this
kamikaze plane coming in low and he
veered you could see with that look
because it was between we were like a
football field a little over a football
field between me and them and the
battleship New Mexico and I see him
coming in low and he fears and goes
right into the bridge of the battleship
New Mexico the explosion was horrendous
and I stood there just I could not
believe it because see my job is to heal
people or try to help him and I'll see a
man giving up his life for the first
time purposely he was alive there and
then he's dead I tell you Ben that stay
with me and plus all the other things
and I wound up I finally when I got home
I said I made it thank God for that but
I was a different type person well in
your book you actually talk a fair bit
about your struggles with the
TSD I was wondering if maybe you could
talk a little bit about that we called
the battle fit you know battles taken
you'll get over it didn't get over it
was getting worse
I win my book my I didn't have it in
there that my daughter made me put it in
my book my daughter Paula and she said
you've got to tell people with your
flashbacks but I said well they was just
horrible
and then finally she said what I think
maybe they'd like to know
well my all the flashbacks from the
different guys are all different but my
flashbacks were I keep seeing him in the
end they'll happen quickly or when I'm
sleeping especially I see the invasion
over and over again I see the body parts
I see the guy screaming mama mama and
it's all magnified and it's just a
horrible feeling and they kept getting
worse
well I when I came out of the Navy I
didn't talk about being in the service I
didn't want to talk about the war
because I figured they'd throw me in
there in insane solemn I'm very honest
with you I'm telling the truth
I felt I would wind up in a you know and
mental institution them want and what
happened in my training I spent a few
weeks or so in the mental institution
taking care of patients and it scared
the heck out of me so I didn't want that
so I'd ever told anyone so finally why
was it the veterans and then finally he
says you ever wounded and I said why I'm
gonna to finally tell you that's us at
66 years and I was doing the craziest
things been I was self medicating myself
with alcohol I was doing so the craziest
things let's say if you were talking to
me and you said Jack I got this problem
so forth I mean you've got a financial
problem I've already checked for 200 and
say here's a gift and I was draining my
bank account was now with not
being refilled and I was trainee and
causing problems from my wife I was
telling bosses off I was doing the
craziest things that I couldn't
understand and I justified what I did
you know well it just turned out that I
wound up finally telling this guy all
these things have happened to me and he
said you've got post-traumatic stress
and I said never heard of it because we
did not know the word post-traumatic
stress so I wound up he set me up with a
therapist like a psychiatrist first and
he gave me one to test then he says you
got some serious problems then he set me
up on a veteran and a guy named Dylan
bender great great man
okay very compassionate well the first
session I had with him and I was
reluctant about going but my first
session with him he took me back to
Normandy and it was so traumatic for me
I was crying and then he said Jack
what we're gonna do is gonna melt those
cubes set of memory in your head and
then we're gonna wind up you will be
able to talk about it and and get back
to normal he says I will see you next
week and in my mind I looked at him and
I thought and I said the hell you will
I'm not coming back because I didn't
want to go through that again
and then I he he said I want you to
think about it so I left and I figured
66 years of doing the craziest things if
you invited me to your house I would not
bring one glass of a bottle of wine I
would bring a magnum of champagne or a
gallon of wine so I would not run out
and I was with my family on Thanksgiving
at my son's house and we are eating or
playing I'm playing I'm drinking all the
wine I brought and everything and when
they set the table on Thanksgiving and I
sat down at the table
brought the meal my face fell right into
the plate in front of my family was the
most embarrassing thing and never gonna
have an intervention with me then my
daughter Paula who was like a therapist
she got me to go to a grief recovery
plan that program she was in she's very
good at it and she got me to finally cut
back on the liquor and from cutting back
on the liquor I finally wound up going
to the the therapist and I went three
and a half years of this therapist and
he finally little by little cured me of
it and then I was able to talk about it
and then finally write a book and this
is this is just kind of a a short book
and all I kept it very honest and and I
kept the book cheap you know just so I I
don't want people I give away a lot of
my books because I want people to know
you don't have to be a end of war to go
through post-traumatic stress disorder
if you've got any kind of stress or any
problem and I tell people when I speak
at different places to get help and if
you know a veteran of the night I plead
with veterans if if you you're a veteran
and you're going through this thing
where you're thinking of a suicide for
God's sakes don't do it please
and it's I say this because what I went
through and I got and now I'm able to
just be free to talk about it I go to
schools and everything else and it makes
the big difference it's being a whole
change in my whole life now I'm sorry I
had to talk so much no please it's I
mean it does raise the question I think
that a lot of people would ask which is
there are thousands of people thousands
of men who I'm sure have experienced the
same thing that you have in terms of
PTSD particularly aftermath of the
things that you've seen what was it
worth it I mean what made it worth it
for America to do this you
the God of War oh absolutely because I'm
I know and I've seen so many things and
in but and talked to so many people you
know in various countries and whatever
may be - we're not perfect but we have
the most wonderful country in the world
I just got through can't I came back
from Washington just this less on Sunday
and it was my first time back there in
many many many years when I was a kid
there and I went through the memorials
to see the memorials touches my heart
and when I saw Arlington I always cry
and I and what was so interesting is
that they had a police escort for the
two buses of you know 60 some people it
was so exciting and the thing that
touched the heart is that they gave us
like females used to get females or not
the letters from different people from
our family they were in personal
envelopes they gave it to us on the
plane while we were going to Washington
and we read them and there wasn't a dry
eye of those veterans hearing from
school kids and and family I got him and
I was crying - the other thing that was
very emotional for me was when I got the
ball tomorrow those people coming from
restaurants and standing out and
applauding just touched your heart you
just could not believe it and then when
we got back to Los Angeles they had a
huge group upstairs and then went
downstairs and somebody a young cadet
comes up with my name on it and says
welcome home jack Guttman and and all
the people applauding I mean you talk
about tears that was a lot of tears
because all of a sudden you realize they
remember you know and it touches a lot
of veterans hearts well thank you for
coming and God bless you I mean you're
the one who's done the service I just
hit her
talk for a living so again thank you so
much it's really an honor to have you
here and I really appreciate your time
so thank you Ben it's an honor and a
pleasure to welcome to set Jorge Champa
is a private first class during Normandy
and actually served in the US Army
graves registration I was wondering can
you tell me what your experiences of
landing on the beaches of Normandy what
was that like well when we got to the
shores of Normandy they say there are
four or five thousand ships out there
and I believe it
ships all around you and the shelling
above us 88 you could hear him screaming
call the Screaming Mimi's but we saw
ships getting hit and I remember tanker
blowing up and there's bodies in the
water and there's debris in the water
and you know I was 18 years old 112
pounds I was a skinny kid
I finally got down a rope ladder and
with all the gear on and I get into a
LCI landing craft that's the smaller
Higgins boats and we're heading in and
could hear the Haiti AIT's screaming
over us and I remember when we started
heading in and we came back out and we
started heading in and we came back out
and I thought it was because of the
shelling and thinking we're gonna get
hit anytime but I found out years later
that the guy that's driving that thing
he's looking for place to land because
the Germans had obstacles in the water
to keep us from getting all the way in
so we had to wade in you've just
probably seen pictures of that and and
so I was so frightened I mean I was
blacked out momentarily I don't remember
getting him off the LCI and I talked to
a buddy of mine years later and I said
hey Gus tell me what happened that we
really weighed in the water he said
don't you remember that I said no he
said what we did we waited in held her
rifle is over our heads and everything
so our job was to gather the dead they
didn't want any dead on the beaches
morale of other troops coming in and and
so we picked up paratroopers that had
landed in the channel there obviously
because I don't know what happened but
they dropped him in the
plays and the parachutes came down over
them these paratroopers are loaded with
the gear and they drown and so we
wrapped them in their parachutes and
buried them we were attached to the to
the first brigade combat engineers for
period provisions and fourth division
landed on that beach on Utah Beach half
of our guys two platoons landed at Omaha
and two at Utah and I was at Utah so can
you talk a little bit about how you
ended up in graves registration what was
that like and what were you doing in the
lead-up to d-day well you got to go back
to when I was a kid because when I was
five years old and again at seven years
old a few situations of family with
deaths and so I had a big fear of death
as a little boy they put me in the in a
Catholic school and he had a ten funeral
masses and so I dropped out of school he
just couldn't couldn't handle it anyway
when they turned 18 I tried to get in
the Air Corps I went down to take the
exam and my eyes were 2022 in so I
flunked so then I got drafted and got
sent to Cheyenne Wyoming and got put in
a graves registration company I said
what the hell is that graves you know
and when I heard what I was gonna have
to do I thought I got to get out of this
well luckily at least temporarily
there was a airbase next to us for
Tauron and they were looking for pilots
this is at March of 44 like three months
before the invasion my brother was in
the Air Corps he was a pilot and the
brother-in-law also and it looked like a
glorious thing to be a part of they
walked with a swagger Pat's tip you know
the girls loved him anyway nobody knows
us except me they lowered the eye
requirements to 20 30 with no glasses
so I could pass that so I took the tests
everything was great they notified my
company commander and you know he hit
the roof and he was very upset I didn't
go to him first of all I just guys were
recruiting and I said hey Here I am
let's go
so anyway there was a company going
overseas right away they were they were
he needed one man so I was
replacement the guys were all older than
I was they were all killing me on the
ship on the way overseas
don't worry Champa they're gonna turn
his ship around take you home Roosevelt
our president said no 18 year old will
set foot on foreign soil nobody knows
that either so we shipped out and on the
way over there in the middle of the
night we're sleeping down in a hold and
all of a sudden is a big explosion and
the ship was rocking everybody's
scurried up on a deck and then found out
that there was a torpedo plane that was
dropping a torpedo and the Navy gunner
shot him down that was a big explosion
and the Navy gunner
I hadn't met the day before he was my
age and he showed me his quarters and we
got acquainted his name was Dennis Reid
from Cincinnati Ohio I never did get in
touch with him after that and I wish I
had because he really saved our lives
can you tell us a little bit about your
experiences digging graves for your
fellow soldiers I saw bodies and
remember had that fear of death I was a
kid I saw bodies and all shapes and
forms for 11 months every day we did
that battle of bulge the other Germany
initiating 17 temporary cemeteries over
11 months somebody in headquarters
figured 75,000 roughly bodies that we
picked up other that's the German and
American because they didn't pick up
their dead and we we put them in you
know mattress covers buried them six
feet down during the battle above the
ground was frozen we had German
prisoners digging the graves I want to
tell you this about gathering the dead
the stench you're not changing clothes
every day and you're sleeping in their
clothes with stench you're spitting
you're dry some of the guys chewed
tobacco whatever we didn't have gloves
that often once in a while we did so it
was it was pretty tough with a stench
for quite a while and this was my job I
broke down one day after a couple of
weeks of that I'm surprised I didn't
before that but lieutenant pulled out
his 45 so you'd get your ass out
suck it up and so I worked like a robot
around these bodies it was tough looking
at faces of guys my age are a little
older and looking at it was grotesque I
mean some of them some of the bodies
were natural-looking but most of them
weren't a lot of them miss missing limbs
are shot up bleeding badly and what for
example I'm gonna give you an example
imagine the tanker getting out of the
turret and he's on fire and he drops
down on the ground and burns up
he's bought of charcoal that's about as
far as I'm gonna go tell you that have
you actually made it back to Normandy
since d-day I didn't want to go I turned
I turned on 8 he was a lieutenant
colonel it was on Utah beaches started a
tour agency called galaxy tours and
Pennsylvania he said look John take you
over there free and take you and your
fiancee and your two kids so we got that
freebie trip and we went over there
before we did anything we're on the tour
bus everybody had to talk about you know
what they did and my son looks at me
after that needs to daddy you never told
us anything about this I said yeah I
know
excuse me
anyway we walked through the cemetery
there Normandy Omaha Beach Colville sur
Mer it's called and I walked alone for a
while and I wondered what bodies I
handled because that's a job we had
handling bodies and walking through the
graves and looking at the looking at the
marble crosses and Stars of David I
noticed that there's no date of birth on
a trust or the crosses or Stars of David
only the date of death and that struck
me and it really bothers me a lot
because when people walk through the
cemetery they have no idea how well
these guys are so I looked at my kids
and I said
you know what your 21 22 now and a lot
of these guys were younger than what you
are now 18 19 20 we know the high price
of freedom they're just words to a lot
of people and I can understand that but
if you see that you know the high price
of freedom so that's what I've been
doing since 2006 I've spoken the
thousands of kids in high schools not
only here but in France and Belgium and
and I stress that no thank you for doing
that and thank you for coming on the
show and doing that because education
really is I think the beginning of of
re-establishing the sort of patriotism
you're talking about George champa
thanks so much for joining this room
thank you well we're working to bring
you all sorts of extra material as a
subscriber when you do subscribe for
$9.99 a month you can hear all sorts of
new information asked extra questions to
all of these amazing soldiers and you
can hear all of that over at daily wire
comm when you become a subscriber for
just $9.99 a month
[Music]
eventually row shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis clever edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and Guillot
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]
you